Kanye West just made a very very good
point
not not not the point that not the thing
that everyone's talking about with Kanye
that as I said I just see no reason
really to address it because I think the
whole debate has become so disingenuous
and it's being pushed in very bad faith
by people who have said and who have
applauded statements far more egregious
than what Kanye West said but by people
like Louis Farrakhan and others
but Kanye West made
a different
good point uh this was on the
Kardashians and you using the
Kardashians as a symbol of how the elite
ought to behave take a listen you know
there's some responsibilities that I
still feel needs to be taken by the
entire family right about the way we
present ourselves everything that we do
we need to present ourselves with the
highest level of nobility when we're in
a position of influence like we are we
have to say do we want our children to
do this and not just our children
everyone's children because we're being
used as an influence to everyone's
children to sell the product that gives
us that affords us the houses that we
put the 800 million security guards in
front of so knowing that to whom is
given much is required much is required
I also require that
to those who are given lots and lots of
things
there is much that is expected
in terms of your responsibility to your
people this of course this this was the
common understanding of what an elite is
until very very recently
and the left has abandoned that the left
has totally denies the the moral order
and says that they're just going to push
their own interests and their own
selfish interests above all others the
right has kind of abandoned this too
though
the right has largely until very
recently abandoned the language of the
common good of the responsibility of the
elite to their Common Man the the right
embraced an idea that sort of greed is
good and I'm in it for me and just do
whatever you want just for yourself and
you know if you're not in the elite
we'll just you know pull yourself up by
your bootstraps and get a job stupid you
know and and yeah of course we want
people to be self-sufficient we want
them to be able to feed themselves and
be strong on their own but they're
if you are in the elite and you don't
have any acknowledgment of your
responsibility to the society which has
afforded you so much
then you can't have a country and you
can't have a society because it's just
so Preposterous to believe that you
individually
are 100 entirely responsible for your
success in life that is not possible the
libs want to pretend that you're zero
percent responsible for your success in
life which is absurd but it's also
absurd to say that you're 100
responsible for your success in life you
have been given many blessings your very
life is a Grace and a blessing okay and
some people are born to a mother and
father who love each other in marriage
that's a great privilege some people are
born in nice neighborhoods some people
are born with a little bit of money some
people are born with privileges
everybody is born with some kind of a
privilege right and some are given a
greater abundance of privileges than
others and there's there's nothing
liberal or leftist about admitting that
that's just called reality and it's
actually a deeply conservative point of
view and that's the point of view that
Kanye West is expressing in that in in
that interview
the idea of a pure meritocracy is not a
conservative idea that is a very liberal
idea that pretends that we're all just
individuals completely divorced from
society but that's not true
what we it's again is that you're just
seeing it's the three points of view
there's the liberal view the libertarian
view and the conservative which I think
takes the best observations of the
liberal View and the libertarian view
here but we do have a responsibility
here the idea of a pure meritocracy does
not get rid of the elite that's one of
the biggest lies that we've been told in
recent decades well you know it's very
wrong and and and uh hierarchical and
old-timey and old-fashioned to have an
elite so what we're going to do is we're
gonna have a pure meritocracy and that's
going to get rid of the elite no it's
not going to get rid of the elite it's
going to replace the old waspy Elite
with a new Elite the difference is that
the new Elite feels absolutely no
obligations to help their fellow man
they're not doing any of the
philanthropic good or a much smaller
portion than the old Elite would but we
do have to have a responsibility it gets
right back to that point on raising our
children
yeah families have the primary
responsibility and right for children
but we all have a political interest in
children because it's our society and so
if our kids are all raised to be
transgender Satan worshipers who are you
know screaming and babbling and chopping
off parts of their body we're going to
live in a crappy society and that's your
problem just as much as it's my problem
so so we have a social and political
right and responsibility to make sure
the kids aren't completely screwed up by
the weirdos in the schools who are doing
that now
[Music]
[Music]